people these days are fascinated by
personality tests and i've never
quite understood why
why do you need a test to tell you who
you are and what your personality is
don't you already know that you are you
aren't you the expert on that who am
i like for me for example i already know
that i'm an insufferable [ __ ] i don't
need a test to tell me that
all that to say today i am going to take
a personality test this one is the um
how do you pronounce that any any
agreement the enemy a graham test
and they have uh apparently there's nine
personality types
that you could choose from so of all
seven billion people on earth and
you only get nine personalities let's
say you gotta choose one of the nine
we will find out which of the nine i am
as we go through this
test that seems like it's way longer
than it needs to be okay
trudy.com is where i took this test and
so then you get options and you have
inaccurate neutral or accurate
i strive for perfection well i don't
know how i can strive for something that
i already have
being a perfect person but uh i i'll
guess i'll say accurate
it is important to me that other people
like me no i don't care what anyone
thinks
i don't think about the oppression i
make on people at all
and i put no effort into it whatsoever
um
and the thing is you should care a
little bit what people think of you and
you should everyone says oh you
shouldn't care what anyone thinks of you
no you should care like i i am what
happens when you don't care at all and
you should care a little bit
don't be like me but i don't so
inaccurate it's important to me to
achieve great things
like see everybody would say accurate to
that right is there anyone who would say
no you know i don't really care about
doing great things i'm kind of in it to
be
to do uh my moderate to satisfactory
things that's what i'm striving for
mediocrity rules
so i'll say accurate um i make more
significant contributions
than the average person well come on
like
i have i have a podcast so um
there's going to be a lot of people in
for a rude awakening when they get to
the pearly gates
and god asks them oh what did you do
with your life like you wouldn't already
know
and they say something like oh i was a
battlefield medic
i served the poor yeah but did you have
a podcast
no get out
i feel my emotions very deeply i have no
emotions
i am on the spectrum for
sociopathy i have a sense that other
people will never truly understand me
this is why i don't like the personality
tests these whiny other people don't
nobody understands me
shut up mom go away you know you know if
you're a human being
you know what it is everyone understands
you and and nobody does at the same time
it's kind of like both because no one is
inside your mind
but at the same time we're all people
and so we kind of get it
because we're all in the same boat as
being people i object to this question i
don't even want to answer it
i pro i boy i protest on principle
uh i am prepared for any disaster no i
have no
skills at all if there's any kind of
disaster
i'm gonna be dead within probably about
45 minutes
it's important to me to avoid pain and
suffering at all times
life is pain life is suffering anyone
who says differently is selling
something you can't avoid it
i seek out experiences that i know will
make me feel happy or excited
who yes as opposed to what of course i
want experiences that make me feel happy
it's got me i don't it's
kind of hard to find them sometimes but
what i see the positive in every
situation though i definitely don't see
the positive in this situation that i'm
in right now
i'm not afraid to tell someone when i
think they're wrong no that's like my
favorite thing to do
actually in the world that's what i do
for a living actually i let other people
make the decisions no
no one can make i don't want anyone to i
don't trust anyone to make any decisions
and i also don't trust myself to make
decisions so
uh i appreciate having rules that people
are expected to follow as a theocratic
fascist of course my answer is accurate
as long as i get to make the rules i
think a lot about what will happen in
the future
does anyone not think about what's
happening in the future
um i don't fit in with ordinary people
everyone is going to say
yes to this no one wants to think that
they don't fit in with
like everyone wants to think that they
don't fit in that they're not ordinary
they're extraordinary
i'm very important every single person
says accurate to this
so in protest i'm gonna say inaccurate
because you know what i do fit it we're
all we all basically are the same
there's rarely a good reason for
changing
how things are done it depends
totally on the situation i can't make a
blanket statement
is it a good idea or a bad idea to
change how things are done
what things are you talking about and
what's the change i i'm not just going
to change how something's done for the
sake of it
i can't answer that question i can't
answer that one either because it
doesn't make any sense
i'm this is going to come back as i have
no person i have i'm going to
be the first person to come back with a
zero i simply am not
there or whatever because i can't i
can't answer any of these questions
i'm always trying to be a better person
everyone's gonna say accurate to that
even though most people aren't
everyone's gonna say that they are they
say there's nine personality types i bet
you there's only one
actually everyone gets the same one
because almost everyone's gonna answer
all these questions the same
the organizations i belong to would not
function well without me
don't tell you something this place
would fall apart if i wasn't doing
youtube videos of myself taking
personality tests about myself
this whole building would crumble okay i
always have a plan for what i would do
if things go wrong
i have a plan it's not always it's
probably not a good one
like my plan for when things go wrong is
always in my head it always involves
drop kicking someone you know like a
karate type of thing
that's always my plan for any situation
i've yet to have a chance to actually do
it but it is a plan so i'll say accurate
i seek excitement i yeah
i have a different idea of what's
exciting probably from the from some
people but
okay these are the spicy cayenne
crickets let's try these
up i am good at seeing the bright side
of things when others complain
no i'm the one doing the complaining so
uh that's got to be inaccurate
i don't hesitate to call people out when
they're behaving badly
yeah that you know again one of my
favorite things to do in fact is that so
i go along with what other people want
i am a die-hard contrarian
so if i know it's what you want i'm just
going to do the opposite
it's a deep deep emotional immaturity
but it has served me well in life
so i'm going to say inaccurate there is
no option on this scale for
this question is stupid so i have to
keep hitting neutral i feel like this is
skewing my results
i seek out relationships that offer me
some type of protection
what am i a chick i am always aware of
what can go wrong in a situation
how many times are we gonna
have the same thing how many times do we
have to teach you this lesson old man
i mean accurate i guess i mean i'm aware
of some of the things that can go wrong
that would lead me to needing to drop
kick somebody but
i like to do things as i've always done
them i mean
if i've done them that way then
obviously i like doing them that way if
i didn't like doing them that way i
wouldn't be doing them that way so if i
am doing them that way i'd like to do
them that way and i'd like to continue
doing them that way
if i want to stop doing them that way
it's because i don't like doing them
that way anymore so therefore i'm still
doing what i want to do so i guess i'll
say accurate
i persist until a task is done
um i wish i could say accurate to that
and i think most people probably would
say accurate but i'm going to admit
and say no that um i often will get
bored and distracted by a squirrel
squirrel
i spend time trying to discover and
correct my faults and weaknesses
i don't like to know about my faults and
weaknesses i hold myself to very high
standards
i'll say accurate to that although i
just said a second ago that i'm not
looking for my faults and weaknesses
so this is real this is really
schizophrenic if i'm honest i feel that
i'm a bit
better than other people well again as
we've established
podcast host number one
number two other reasons
i am better than you i am an unusual
sort of person
i'll say accurate this is why this is
six pages long because it's the same
they have three questions they repeat
each one of them 30 times it's important
to be
to be prepared for any emergency we just
did this
oh no that the question there was am i
prepared and i said no
but is it important for me to be
prepared even though i'm not
yes i think it's important i just don't
do it
i tend to be more optimistic than most
people well obviously not inaccurate i
tell people what i think even if it's
hard to hear
yes of course i would rather follow the
group than push for what i want
inaccurate i'm just gonna i got to just
roll through these this has been going
on forever
i set ambitious goals for myself i think
we've established a million times that
i do set goals yes i'm an important
member of
of my social group we we did literally
that same question didn't we
what did i say accurate who cares okay
we just got to get through this
i make alliances with people who can
help me stay safe and secure
i mean inaccurate because that's not
what i'm thinking about that what do you
mean make an alliance with a person what
is a survivor
i enjoy caring for others and their
needs
depends on who it is you know if it's my
family
that's pretty much it that's the extent
of the people that i enjoy caring for
but i'll put accurate
um i believe that things usually work
out for the best
well clearly they don't okay finally
we're on the last page praise
jesus okay we're just going to run
through these i make important
contributions to my community um
yes podcast i feel i never truly belong
in social groups
um dumb question neutral i want to learn
as much as i can about how the world
works
yeah everyone does trying new things
keeps life interesting
accurate i'm an upbeat person no i am
usually the one to take a stand when
others won't
i'll say yes other people have stronger
opinions than i do probably not
sure i'll say accurate everyone has a
role to play in society and a duty to do
their best
uh sure yes i am concerned with
protecting what i have
yes obviously i have a good sense of
what my future holds okay fine
i'm about to throw my computer across
the freaking room
i try new ways of doing things just to
see if they will work
um sure okay fine self-improvement is a
major interest of mine
and we'll just call that a yes because i
want to get to the results and finally
we've completed that and let's find out
what my personality is
here's what we find out i have a 98
match with an eight what is an eight
eights see themselves as strong and
powerful and seek to stand up for what
they believe in
they rarely see themselves as having
vulnerabilities and have the belief that
they can handle pretty much anything
that comes their way
eights have easy access to their anger
have easy access to their anger
what does that mean i can feel your
anger is that a positive way of putting
they are hot heads and
they have a bad temper which obviously
is the case because i've been screaming
at this test the entire time
um and as a result sometimes seem as
seen as intimidating to others
however aids typically see themselves as
fighters standing up
for what is right and protecting the
weak but i also have a 77
match with a one ones are defined by
their belief that everything must be in
order and by their feeling that they
must always be
right they show great commitment and
determination to improve conditions
that they find need improvement and they
are forward and encouraging others
to improve their performance to you know
what i think it is
i am an enigma i am a mystery
[Music]
to myself into the world
i think that is what we have learned
from this personality test mainly
because we have to stop this video
at some point thanks for watching